To understand threads more deeply, it's important to have a
clear picture of a traditional process and its address space.
Typically, at the lower addresses, a process will have the
instructions followed by literals, that is values in the code, then
statically allocated memory, really, global variables, and then the heap.
Which will grow upwards. And then at the top of
the address space and working its way down, we have
the current stack of a process. Remember that the stack includes
all the information local to a procedure. Parameters, local
variables, and the address of the instruction to return to
when the current procedure is over. In a multithreaded
environment, each thread has it's own stack, but it shares
everything else with the original main thread of the
process. So, from a certain perspective, a thread acts like
an entire process unto itself, and hence threaded programming
isn't much different from a traditional programming. The difference comes
from the fact that part of the memory is shared. On the
one hand, this makes it very easy for threads to communicate. But
it also means that extra care is needed to make sure that
the threads coordinate as they use this memory. I should point out
as well, that one can do parallel programming without having multiple threads.
Each parallelizable task could have it's own process with it's own address
space. And it could communicate with
the other processes through message passing.
In fact if we wanted to take advantage of a distributed system,
where each processor has it's own separate physical memory, we would be
forced to use this approach. As
we think about multi-threaded programming, however, the
paradigm explored in this lesson, is more appropriate to think of a shared
memory system, where we have multiple cores sharing a common piece of memory.